[Musique]
connaissez-vous l'expression avancer à
un train de sénateur ça veut dire y
aller doucement tranquillement
prudemment pépère quoi c'est un peu
moqueur parce que depuis toujours on
taquine le Sénat le Sénat c'est la
deuxème chambre du Parlement on
l'appelle la chambre haute parce qu'on
peut pas la dissoudre et parce qu'elle
n'est pas élue directement par le peuple
la chambre basse c'est l'Assemblée
nationale avec ses députés les deux
chambres ont le même rôle le vote de la
loi est le contrôle du gouvernement mais
la plus importante c'est celle du bas
pour voter les lois ce sont les députés
de l'Assemblée nationale qui en cas de
désaccord entre les deux assemblées ont
le dernier mot je vous raconte ça en
détail dans un autre épisode alors à
quoi sert le Sénat s'il ne peut jamais
s'imposer à prendre son temps justement
les sénateurs sont des parlementaires
qui ont le temps de réfléchir sur chaque
loi de vérifier qu'elles sont vraiment
applicables et nécessaires qu'elles ne
sont pas trop sévères ou trop
brutales les débats au Sénat moins
médiatisés sont plus calmes et apaisés
parce que les sénateurs ne ne sont pas
élus directement par les électeurs au
début de la République on disait du
Sénat que c'était la chambre des anciens
la chambre des sages comme si on devait
se méfier de la souveraineté populaire
bref beaucoup d'appellations pour une
très vieille assemblée à l'allure un peu
désuette on imagine de vieux sénateurs
ventripotant et dormant pendant les
débats on dit aussi qu'ils ramolissent
la force des lois votées par les députés
qu'il retarde l'application de ses lois
évidemment tout cela est un peu plus
compliqué par exemple il a de plus en
plus de femmes au Sénat si l'Assemblée
nationale et les députés représentent
les sensibilités politiques de la
population le Sénat est fait plutôt pour
représenter la diversité des territoires
de la France on dit que le Sénat c'est
la chambre de l'histoire et de la
géographie les sénateurs ont un mode de
désignation très complexe ils sont élus
par un collège de 150000 grands
électeurs ce collège est composé d'élus
locaux Isabelle la maire d'une grande
ville de 300000 habitants et Gérard le
maire d'un petit ville village de 68
habitants vote tous les deux pour les
sénateurs et comme il y aura toujours
plus de villages que de grandes villes
on dit que les sénateurs représente
plutôt la France des campagnes que la
France des
villes les sénateurs élisent le
président du Sénat ce personnage dont
très peu de Français connaissent le nom
a un rôle très important si le président
de la République venait à mourir ou à
démissionner et bien c'est le président
du Sénat qui le remplacerait le temps
d'organiser d'autres élections comme
quoi même en avançant un train de
sénateur
on peut atteindre le sommet de
[Musique]
l'État